we're gonna talk about the game of
Amazon's it was invented in Argentina by
a chap named Wohlers em cows cows I
believe in the 1980s so it's a fairly
new game for purposes of this video I
think we should use only a 6x6 board
because this makes the game faster this
is a good game for kids at that size
the official size preferred by Sam cows
cows is 10 by 10 which is also the size
of a checkerboard in Argentina and you
can also play an 8 by 8 or be playing
any size ur could even be a rectangular
board well there's two black pieces and
two white pieces and there are various
possible starting configurations this is
one that I like a legal move is let's
just take one piece here a legal move is
buy an Amazon if you choose to move this
Amazon you can go as far as it wants in
any direction either diagonal or
horizontal or vertical like a chess
queen now after it moves it must shoot
an arrow and the arrow also goes like a
chess queen the same Amazon that moved
must also shoot so maybe it shoots like
that okay now the square in which it
lands this is like a flaming arrow it is
burned off the board and that square
cannot be occupied nor can any other
Amazon jump over it or capture it
there's no capturing all the Amazons are
immortal they run about shooting flaming
arrows and eventually the board gets
blocked up with flaming arrows and
somebody can't move and when that
happens because they're unable to move
and the game's over and the player
unable to move is the player who loses
Oh
the player who did the last legal move
is the winner
that's right okay yes
sounds fun okay well it is Brady's gonna
play black and I'm gonna play white and
we're gonna play again well let's say
you can go first
it is believed there is an advantage to
going first but no one really knows I'm
gonna go so okay there and then so I
could shoot my arrow for example - there
sure
that's okay all right here and there I'm
gonna go to yeah shoot my alright okay
[Music]
so here I'm feeling that black player
getting a bit pinned in there so for
example I'm Maru I might move to here
and then try and start penning in you're
white you're white hammers on there yep
that's highly plausible so I'll go here
and shoot there okay okay here and shoot
to that okay
was that a good or a bad knife hard for
me at all I think I better let's go here
and shoot here okay my black player is
getting quite pinned in there isn't he
yeah I feel like I need to get that guy
out of trouble because if because I
could get boxed in here quite easily
couldn't I true so I'm gonna I'm gonna
come down to here and then I have my
arrow yeah well that works to some
extent are you feeling good about your
situation yeah yeah yeah so now the
board is split into two games there's
one over here and which I'm Way ahead
cuz I have a lot of space and you have
only one and there's another game over
here this divides the board into two
pieces
is this commenting in in in games for
games to get split into sub games like
this certainly in the kind of character
games that we study yes because that's a
big part of how we manage to do an
analysis because in the mathematics we
can do an analysis this side of the
board the result is not gonna be too
complicated because this is fairly
simple this over here is still fairly
complicated but we can do an analysis
over here we do another analysis over
here and then we have ways of adding
these two analyses together to get an
analysis of the whole game is there a
name for this this this tecnique divide
and conquer it feels like I'm I'm pretty
dead over this side now like over here
there's a lot more at stake yeah there's
some squares back here you will probably
get and there's some squares down here
that more likely I will get there's some
of the middle that we'll be fighting
over so okay presumably these two will
be fighting for a while it's mine maybe
but the name isn't yes I mean okay yeah
yeah okay so I think I will just go here
and shoot here yes so now I have one two
three four five you have one two three
four five six seven okay unless I can
move again which I'm they come on here
argue with you okay but at the moment
you have two moves more than I do here
probably roughly not and over here I
have one two three four five six six or
seven moves ahead of you okay
here fire here so no this is sort of
interesting like come in after you I you
may cut me off so I'm not sure what the
best plan is here I probably do that
anyway I'll come in and I'm gonna be
okay and still get three points extra
but if you don't I'll back up and get
all these yeah okay okay here and fire
here so then I come here and shoot here
okay so I only have one possible move
which is to go here and fire here all
right yeah yeah now I start using it my
moves here and now I can't move I can't
move I can't move that I can't move that
that I still have one two three four
five six seven eight no even if you had
no more moves you've won the game that's
right that's right some sense we say
have won by nine points there's only
there's only one game against the
beginner I've ever lost out of somewhere
like 40 now you should have told me that
before I would have I would have tried
hard if I knew the stakes was that high
judo Jang who is a famous nine down go
player beat me the first game of
Amazon's we played okay although I
challenged him to rematch and I won the
second there are a number of levels at
which it helps teach mathematics for
very small children the beginners just
observing that we have we have addition
here we have one two three four five six
seven moves for white here and two moves
here so he wins by nine points let's
let's let's assume this end at some
different way something
like that for instance suppose suppose
the game it ended like this
see well I would have preferred that
well black has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 moves white
has 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 moves but white has
another one so white is ahead by one
point
white is one move ahead so he will win
even if he has to go first
now I after this for instance it's now 7
vs. 7 and the mover will lose because
this adds up to zero so in general we
say game is worth zero when the mover
cannot win so zero game is 1 which is
well a win for the second player the
original game as prescribed by a dozen
house there's a 10 by 10 board and each
side starts with 4 Amazons on an 8x8 we
usually have 3 against 3 and on a 6x6
it's usually two against two
when one no we have an experienced
player playing against the beginner as I
just stood against I'm Brady be more
interesting game if I gave him 3
Amazon's against my two so that's
sometimes you pick you play that way
they hand you can sure sure that's one
way to handicap the other just find a
starting position in which one sides
already more constrained than the other
and so you can start from positions that
are biased and in one direction or
another well yeah I think it's
interesting game I and I think the
opening sir I don't understand I don't
think anybody does it's a game that is
played
there have been international
tournaments back in the early days of
Amazon's they were played by fax and now
I'm sure everything's computerized there
are people do research in it yes there
are
Martin Mueller at the University of
Alberta has done a fair amount of work
as have some other people and and trying
to evaluate sizes of various positions
and I think by now it's sort of known
how to play on very small boards maybe
four by four
I don't think six by sixes really
understood yet the board has no
direction I mean all all directions are
equally good in that sense it's more
like go than like chess or checkers were
there is a forward component built into
the game this game has no forward
zazen house starting position has the
four blocks on one side and lined up
against the foreign the other which i
think is a little distracting the
beginners because you it it sort of
conveys this notion of forward motion
coming at each other but after a few
moves each side gets around behind the
other usually and it's it's it's up for
grabs there is no the board really has
no direction
region here throw zero because there's
no Amazon but it turns out each of these
positions is worth a half a point for a
black run a chain through here and the
only way you're gonna be able to stop it
as a sacrifice a box don't don't give
away any sacrifice until you have to
stop the side chains right away